est-ce que vous saviez que au début
Skoda fabriqué des vélos en fait c'était
pas vraiment Skoda c'était deux frangins
c'était Clément et Laurine qui sont dit
ben on va fabriquer des vélos parce
qu'en fait on trouve pas ce qui nous
plaît alors ils ont fabriqué des vélos
ils ont fabriqué des motos et différents
types de véhicules avant d'arriver alors
première voiture avant de se faire
racheter par une grosse boîte qui
s'appelait Skoda et qui à l'époque
fabriqué notamment des armes à feu ça
c'est la toute première superbe qui a
été lancé quand même une voiture dans
notre temps on voyage vraiment dans le
temps ici véhicule là je crois que c'est
un les années enfin les années 50 années
60 c'était la toute première Octavia
donc c'est quand même pas mal voyez
brandé Skoda après on s'est retrouvé
avec la 1000 MB qui a quand même une
classe dingue puis après on arrive je
crois que c'est dans les années 180
année 90 avec la favorite de Skoda bien
évidemment je sais pas si vous le saviez
mais en fait au début Skoda c'était
l'histoire de deux frangins et qui ont
fait des vélos